here's what would happen if you were  swallowed by a hippo  if you see a hippo open its mouth in a  yawn or laugh you're in trouble this is  a sign it's going to attack  if a hippo starts to eat you you'd feel  intense pressure as it began to crush  your arms or legs with its teeth you  could punch the hippo right in the nose  to loosen its grip on your body but  although you might manage to break free  you'd be in bad shape you'd most likely  be missing an arm  an arm that would be now traveling down  the hippo's throat  it would then go into the first chamber  of its stomach where micro bacteria  would begin to break down your arm  then your arm would pass on to the true  stomach where the digestive enzymes  would continue to break it down  later the hippo would poop remnants of  your arm and some grass all over its  territory so while some hippos can be  cute you should always steer clear of  them because